de notre second débat consacré à la
justice restaurative c'est le film très
réussi de janeiry je verrai toujours vos
visages qui nous a donné envie d'en
savoir plus sur cette proposition de
dialogue de discussion faites aux
victimes et aux auteurs de crimes et des
lits l'objectif il est double soulager
les séquelles psychologiques des
victimes évitez la récidive des auteurs
avant d'en évaluer les capacité avec nos
invités nos experts regarder ses
premiers témoignages recueillis par
Fabien Recker
c'est une mort absurde qui frappe en
2009 la famille de Martine Mervoyer
c'était la fin de l'année scolaire et
Martin avec des copains a décidé de
partir en passer une semaine encore son
fils Martin 19 ans est abattu par le
videur d'une discothèque où il faisait
la fête suite à une banale dispute
reconstitution procès la famille entame
un long chemin de réparation quand une
connaissance propose un Martin de
participer à un programme de justice
restaurative à la prison de Poissy il
s'agit de faire dialoguer entre eux
auteur et victime d'infraction pénales
j'ai senti que c'était une voix pour moi
d'aller dans ce milieu là je savais pas
ce que j'en retirerais mais en tous les
cas j'ai reçu ça un peu comme un appel
quelque chose d'important disons
d'important pour donner du sens en fait
à ce qui n'en n'a pas à la mort d'un
enfant ça n'a pas de sens des rencontres
préparées et encadrées qui portent
les gens se relèvent les détenus se
relèvent les victimes se relèvent et il
y a comme une
fraternité une qui qui permet à chacun
de retrouver
une manière de se remettre debout se
remettre debout c'est ce qui a poussé
Rémi à s'engager dans la démarche en
2022 ce père de famille est condamné
pour violence conjugale à 24 mois de
mise à l'épreuve avec obligation de
soins psychologiques Rémi veut aller
plus loin sa conseillère pénitentiaire
lui propose alors la justice
restaurative sur le moment ça m'a fait
un peu peur ensuite il faut dire qu'on a
été bien encadré une préparation de
plusieurs mois est nécessaire auprès
d'un médiateur de l'association d'aide
aux victimes le processus est volontaire
et inconditionnel il ne permet aucune
remise de peine pour les auteurs je me
souviens de la première fois c'est qu'on
était dans la pièce en étant un cercle
et devant nous il y avait des femmes qui
étaient victimes de violences conjugales
donc au début personne
osé parler parce que c'était pas évident
c'est qu'on est auteurs conjugale face à
des personnes qui ont vécu ça qui nous
souffert au fur et à mesure des sessions
ça c'est dénoué et chacun a raconté un
petit peu son passé et comment on a été
tous plus ou moins arrivé là au contact
des victimes Rémi affirme avoir pris
conscience des mécanismes et des
conséquences de la violence conjugale
aujourd'hui je suis personnellement
resté en contact avec une des victimes
on s'appelle quand ça va pas quand on a
des baisses de morale on s'entraîne en
fait et il est évident que que
j'ai entendu pourraient jamais les
oublier on ne peut pas oublier on peut
pas oublier
si on peut pas oublier c'est que
forcément on n'est pas prêt à
recommencer responsabiliser les auteurs
aider à la reconstruction des victimes
encore confidentielles en France la
justice restaurative peut être un
complément au traitement pénal des
infractions
vous ne connaissez peut-être sans doute
pas la justice restaurative on va
vouloir présenter de l'intérieur grâce à
nos invités Benjamin saillouz bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directeur de
l'Institut français pour la justice
restaurative Frédéric Giffard avocate
bonsoir bienvenue Cédric legelin bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes magistrat
porte-parole du ministère de la Justice
et puis avec nous en duplex également
Jérôme Moreau vice-président
porte-parole de la fédération France
victime bonsoir vous êtes également
vice-président de victimes supportent
Europe et Mathilde Sirault évidemment
est resté à mes côtés la justice
restaurative Benjamin saillou s'il y a
peut-être beaucoup de noter les
spectateurs qui ont pas vu le film de
janeiri je verrai toujours au visage et
qui découvre ces mots c'est quoi votre
définition c'est quoi c'est vraiment
accompagner les personnes qui souhaitent
pouvoir dialoguer sur ce qui s'est passé
à l'issue d'une infraction que ce soit
la victime l'auteur pouvoir aborder le
pourquoi le comment ça s'est passé et
surtout ce qu'ils ont pu vivre après
toute la victimisation secondaire les
souffrances liées à l'impact de
l'infraction pour les victimes le
traitement pénal aussi pour ce qui est
des auteurs l'impact sur leur famille et
tout cela c'est quelque chose dont les
personnes ont besoin pour envisager un
avenir et donc notre travail pour ceux
qui animent ces mesures de justice
restaurative leur permettre de dialoguer
en toute sécurité parfois on se
rencontrant dans le film c'est Denis
podalyse qui est un peu le chef de c'est
vous alors non le personnage je crois
qui est beaucoup inspiré de professeurs
Robert Carriot qui a amené la justice
reste d'accord en France et qui est le
fondateur de notre institut d'accord
très bien
Frédéric Giffard justement Denis dans le
film il a une formule il dit la justice
restaurative c'est un sport de combat
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
formule alors c'est drôle parce que moi
je me suis intéressée à la justice
restaurative parce que au bout de 20 ans
22 ans de métier d'avocat je trouvais
que justement on était trop j'étais trop
loin en tout cas dans le combat dans la
diversité et je me posais des questions
sur est-ce que c'est ça que client
veulent est-ce que c'est ça dont ils ont
besoin et donc la justice restaurative
c'est une des une des justices
alternatives finalement qui permettent
de réduire cet adversité alors j'imagine
que c'est un sport de combat parce que
ça va à l'encontre
beaucoup de
valeurs fortes et de tendance de fond de
notre société et ça on pourra en parler
parce que c'est un peu un changement
culturel qu'il faudrait
opérer pour que la justice soit hâtive
prenne toute la place qu'elle mérite
mais en tout cas ça vient au contraire
apaiser apaiser les relations apaiser
les relations vous l'avez vécu vous avez
accompagné des clients dans dans ces
démarches pas encore parce que les c'est
très récent en France ça la loi date de
2014 la circulaire de 2017
il y a eu le covid entre temps il y a
très peu pour l'instant de mesures qui
sont réellement effectives et les
avocats ne sont pas partis du processus
donc
moi je rêve d'un système où il y aurait
beaucoup plus de justice restaurative je
rêve d'un système notamment où les
victimes de violences sexuelles
pourraient choisir entre la justice
pénale et la justice restaurative et
dans ce cadre là je pense que les
avocats auraient toute leur toute leur
rôle à jouer alors effectivement vous
disiez ça concerne pour l'instant à peu
de monde on a les chiffres de 2021 54
personnes qui en ont bénéficié en 2021
d'une mesure de justice restaurative ça
veut dire quoi Cédric logelin pour
l'instant pour le ministère de la
justice c'est encore au stade un peu
expérimental comment qu'est-ce que vous
diriez là-dessus alors c'est ce n'est
pas au stade expérimental puisque les
textes existent depuis le 1er octobre
2014 ensuite le ministère de la Justice
a
élargi en fait la connaissance des
professionnels sur la justice
restaurative puisque on a des
informations qui ont été qui sont
parvenus au magistrat aux professionnels
sous la forme de circulaire et de décret
en 20 21 2022 pour les aider à
s'approprier la justice restaurative il
y a des formations qui sont dispensées
par l'École Nationale de
l'Administration Pénitentiaire par
l'École nationale de la Protection
Judiciaire de jeunesse auprès de la
magistrature également il y a un guide
méthodologique qui a été fait en
concertation avec avec l'Institut pour
les majeurs pour les mineurs je précise
que peu connu par nos interrompre
nous on fait cette émission il y a eu
pas mal de médiatisation avec le film de
janneyri mais je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de victimes qui imaginent même
pas se lancer dans une démarche comme ça
peut-être que certains ou certaines qui
nous regardent vont se dire tiens mais
pourquoi pas justement l'enjeu c'est de
mieux la faire connaître et de faire
appel à une association des do victime
d'ailleurs j'invite les personnes qui
qui nous regardent à regarder quelle est
l'association qui est proche de chez
elle pour solliciter de bénéficier d'une
mesure de justice restaurative sur le
site du ministère vous avez la
l'annuaire des associations et vous
allez trouver la plus proche de chez
vous et vous allez pouvoir peut-être et
bien avoir une aide de la part d'une
association qui la met déjà en œuvre
c'est le c'est améliorer l'information
de tous avec d'autres chiffres qui
viennent de votre institut 83 mesures de
justice et de soratives en cours de
réalisation donc ça veut dire enfin
voilà on va expliquer ce que ce que les
différentes options et 131 bénéficiaires
concernés donc effectivement on est
encore dans des dans des voilà dans des
proportions dans
pas de masse quoi voilà c'est vraiment
quelques dizaines de Français et on
pourrait presque dire que ces
confidentiel d'une certaine d'une
certaine façon Jérôme Moreau vous êtes
je me tourne vers vous qui est avec nous
en duplex en visioconférence je vous
rappelle le porte-parole de la de la
fédération France victime un peu à
l'origine de la l'arrivée en France de
ce de ce système est-ce qu'on peut dire
ça
oui puisque c'est un processus dont nous
parlons depuis 2007 donc vous voyez ça
fait déjà quelques années
pratiquement 16 ans aujourd'hui c'était
le Conseil national de la doctolib team
qui avait qui avait posé cela dans le
cadre du ministère de la Justice et puis
peu à peu on a fait les premières
mesures première mesure 2010 à Poissy
avec effectivement robert cariot Paul et
manzulu et puis après on est allé voir
les exemples du Canada on est parti au
Canada se former on est revenu avec tout
cela et puis la loi est arrivée et on a
formé pratiquement toutes les
associations en lien avec l'Institut
français de justice restaurative
pourquoi les victimes en ont-elles
besoin pourquoi la réponse pénale ne
suffit pas alors je pense que
on attend beaucoup du procès en disant
que le procès un effet thérapeutique
extraordinaire et qu'il permet de tout
résoudre c'est pas forcément vrai c'est
sans doute vrai sur le plan du droit
c'est sans doute vrai sur le plan
d'indemnisation sur le plan de la
réparation psychologique sur le de la
réparation des séquelles c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué et on a trouvé dans ces
exemples Canadiens notamment l'idée que
des rencontres entre les auteurs et les
victimes étaient de nature à pouvoir
restaurer les victimes et je rappelle
que la restauration s'est revenu à
l'état d'avant l'infraction et donc il
fallait trouver ce processus et que ce
processus était extrêmement salvateur
pourquoi parce que les victimes vont
pouvoir s'exprimer de manière totalement
libre
sans avoir à subir les vicissitudes du
procès pénal et les problématiques liées
au procès pénal et là on est dans une
totale liberté elles peuvent s'exprimer
tout comme les auteurs d'ailleurs et
elles doivent entendre des choses des
auteurs que le procès pénal ne permet
pas et c'est cette liberté à mon avis
absolue qui permet à tout le monde de
pouvoir se restaurer alors on va
continuer de détailler tout ça et je
propose à atteindre traduit de nous
rejoindre de nouveaux sur ce sur ce
plateau bonsoir Tam parce que bon je
l'ai dit en amorce de ce débat
évidemment ces termes ce dispositif est
très peu connu en France donc vous allez
nous le détailler et revenir peut-être
au point de départ on l'a évoqué à
l'instant d'où vient cette pratique oui
le pays pionnier que l'on cite le plus
sur la justice restaurative ou justice
réparatrice on parle aussi de justice
réparatrice c'est le Canada c'est un
pays où se développe déjà depuis une
trentaine d'années les structures les
programmes qui font se rencontrer les
victimes et les auteurs d'infraction les
initiatives elles existent déjà depuis
les années 70 mais le code pénal
Canadien a posé un cadre juridique à ces
mesures en 1996 et ensuite et bien la
justice restaurative a été encouragée
par une loi d'abord pour les adolescents
avant qu'en 2014 et bien la loi
canadienne permet le recours à des
mesures de justice restaurative à tous
stades de la procédure pour les adultes
on l'a évoqué cette date 2014 elle fait
son apparition dans le droit français et
oui la loi du 15 août 2014 sur
l'individualisation de la peine à fixer
le cadre reconnu aujourd'hui écrit par
le code pénal et puis il y a eu ensuite
une circulaire en 2017 quelles sont les
grands principes de la justice
restera-t-il générale supposent d'abord
l'information le consentement de la
victime et de l'auteur de l'infraction
ensuite cela suppose la présence d'un
tiers indépendant formé à la justice
restaurative par exemple un CEPI un
conseiller pénitentaire d'insertion et
de probation ensuite tout doit se passer
sous le contrôle de l'autorité
judiciaire ou de l'administration
pénitentiaire et enfin tout cela et bien
c'est confidentiel sauf exception s'il y
a par exemple l'accord des parties alors
on parle de mesure de justice
restaurative quels sont-elles et bien
voilà il y a plusieurs choses possibles
d'abord bien des rencontres condamnées
victimes ou détenus victimes vous avez
entre 3 et 5 victimes et 3 à 5 condamnés
pour un même type d'infraction mais ce
ne sont pas les mêmes affaires d'abord
vous n'avez pas un condamné et sa
victime ensemble dans ses cercles il se
réunissent il se rencontre 5 à 6 fois
avec un tiers indépendant formé et aussi
des représentants bénévoles de la
société civile et il parle ainsi
ensemble des répercussions de
l'infraction commise vous avez aussi les
cercles de soutien et de responsabilités
qui sont destinées aux auteurs
d'infractions sexuels qui sont en fin de
peine et qui présentent un risque élevé
de récidive c'est ça qui sont composés
de bénévoles formés et cela vise à la
réinsertion sociale puis il y a aussi
une autre forme alors là on parle de
médiation on n'est plus dans un face à
face exactement là vous avez le tiers
formé par exemple donc le conseiller
d'insertion et de probation dont je
parlais qui va voir alternativement la
victime et l'auteur de l'infraction il
va faire des entretiens préparatoires
pour entendre leur version des faits les
répercussions sur leur vie et ensuite ce
n'est pas obligatoire la victime et
l'auteur d'infraction se rencontrent en
face à face avec la présence du
médiateur on peut faire la même chose et
on l'étend même à la famille c'est ce
qu'on appelle la conférence restaurative
ou conférences de groupe familial et ça
peut être très utile notamment pour les
partenaires et enfin vous avez même ce
que l'on appelle les cercles
restauratifs c'est à dire que lorsqu'il
y a eu par exemple un nom lieu une
prescription lorsqu'il y a une relax
l'objectif là encore c'est d'apporter de
l'apaisement à toutes les personnes
concernées merci beaucoup Tam Benjamin
saillous c'est face à face donc là on
est c'est bien ce que tu aimes nous
expliquer entre une victime et l'auteur
de de des acteurs voilà
ça c'est ce qui est le plus demandé
aujourd'hui actuellement oui c'est
l'essentiel de la pratique après ce
qu'il faut bien entendre aussi c'est que
tout notre travail il va consister à
accompagner les personnes dans ce
processus là qui va leur permettre de
déterminer aussi ce qu'elles veulent
aborder les limites de de leurs
processus c'est-à-dire est-ce que va
être en capacité de pouvoir aller
jusqu'au bout de ce dialogue et la
rendant n'est pas forcément
indispensable oui mais alors on parle de
quoi on parle de crime par exemple
absolument c'est sur des faits de qui
peuvent être extrêmement graves violent
inceste en matière de conjugale on
maintient de violence volontaire
braquage on a eu en matière de
terrorisme aussi voilà donc tout cela
c'est quelque chose qui apporte
énormément aux personnes et on a
constaté que plus l'infraction est grave
plus ça marche Mathilde est-ce que vous
diriez que c'est davantage les personnes
condamnées ou les victimes qui se
montrent désireuses de faire appel à ce
genre de médiation en fait vraiment
c'est les deux en fait aussi on se rend
compte qu'en fait ça dépend de du degré
d'information dont ils vont disposer on
se rend compte actuellement que
l'information n'est pas toujours
systématique pour que ce soit pour les
victimes ou pour les auteurs mais
lorsqu'on leur en parle bien en fait
beaucoup de personnes sont intéressées
par ces processus là et donc on a autant
des demandes du côté des condamnés que
du côté des victimes lorsque c'est
uniforme après un certain nombre de
territoires ne pas le même niveau
d'information et là ça dépend avoir plus
de victimes parfois plus d'auteurs alors
dans ce déb va s'appuie évidemment sur
des extraits du film de de janeiry on a
remercié la production de nous les avoir
fournis alors c'est justement une scène
2 de médiation elle est demandée par le
personnage de Chloé qui est incarné par
Adèle Exarchopoulos elle a été violée
enfant par son frère aîné celui-ci il a
été condamné mais il réapparaît dans sa
ville elle cherche une solution auprès
d'une fonctionnaire de justice
restaurative qui est incarné par Elodie
Bouchez regardez j'aimerais revoir mon
frère mais je veux pas le revoir comme
ça dans un café ou je sais pas où il est
mais il est revenu vivre ici apparemment
c'est ma cousine qui m'a prévenu et je
veux
j'ai pas envie de le croiser par hasard
enfin je veux le voir pour être sûr de
mal croiser par hasard avant il avait
une mesure éloignement mais maintenant
c'est plus le cas et je peux pas
l'empêcher de revenir vivre ici il
fréquentait certains endroits donc c'est
ça en fait faut juste qu'on se mette
d'accord sur des trucs
ben quand est-ce qu'il va aller au
cimetière
au cinéma à la piscine ça c'est le
minimum et certains cafés aussi
peut-être certains restaurants quel jour
quels horaires
je sais pas comment vous vous organisez
ça dans un premier temps on va préciser
vos attentes
Frédéric Giffard ce moment ou un ou un
une personne qui a été condamnée qui a
purgé sa peine sort de prison et enfin
il y a quoi il y a il peut y avoir cette
peur chez chez la victime vous l'avez
souvent je sais pas si vous gardez le
contact forcément avec les avec les
clients que vous avez accompagnés mais
oui avec certains d'entre eux bien sûr
et la sortie de prison c'est c'est un
vrai problème mais la prison aussi peut
être un problème
chez une victime qui comme dans le film
connaît son agresseur ou son violeur
dont elle est parfois très très proche
avec avec laquelle il peut y avoir un
rapport affectif qui rend la situation
très complexe qui peut la faire
culpabiliser d'avoir envoyé cette
personne en prison qui peut la faire
culpabiliser d'avoir
fait exploser la famille
il y a des interrogations tout le long
tout le long du parcours pénal et qui ne
sont pas du tout purgés par le procès
voilà le procès pénal dans un dossier
comme celui-ci comme dans beaucoup
d'autres ça peut être une expérience
extrêmement frustrante pour tout le
monde et la justice restera-t-il elle
vient aussi pour
justement pour compléter pour compléter
le pénal parce que dans le pénal il faut
bien voir que
il y a un accusé qui va chercher à
sauver sa peau
il a pas le système pénal actuel en
France n'incite pas du tout un accusé à
faire ce dont la victime a besoin c'est
à dire reconnaître les faits
c'est-à-dire s'expliquer c'est à dire
éventuellement présenter des excuses ce
dialogue là
il est pas du tout encouragé par le
système pénal notamment quand il y a pas
d'autres preuves si vous voulez on va
pas demander à quelqu'un de s'auto
incriminer c'est tout à fait logique que
ce soit
parquet de faire la preuve de sa
culpabilité donc le résultat c'est qu'il
y a beaucoup d'acquittements beaucoup de
non-lieu et il y a aussi beaucoup de
situations dans lesquelles les personnes
sont condamnées mais on a laissé de côté
toutes les choses qui étaient
importantes pour la victime alors moi
pendant toute cette partie du film ça se
ça se ça se tisse ça se mélange avec les
séances collectives
j'ai peur de la rencontre entre le
personnage d'Adèle exact kopoulos et
puis celui qui de son frère aîné Cédric
logelin Le évidemment c'est une évidence
mais il faut peut-être le rappeler la
sécurité de la victime elle est elle est
prioritaire donc ça veut dire qu'on peut
interrompre le processus à tout moment
c'est ça tout à fait alors la justice
restera-t-il implique que les deux
soient d'accord et qu'ils étaient
informés préalablement à cet accord
ensuite chacun peut arrêter le le
dispositif à tout moment
des deux côtés et bien entendu lorsque
l'échange a lieu il est fait en présence
manager spécialement formé qui peut être
un éducateur qui peut être un conseiller
pénitentiel qui peut être un membre
d'association
sa rate parfois pardon d'être non mais
je le fais sous le film mais globalement
positif mais des fois ces rencontres
n'ont pas lieu ce que recherche la
victime elle le trouve pas parce qu'elle
a un mur en face d'elle ça arrive et en
fait comme l'enjeu de la préparation
visa bien connaître les attentes de la
personne et qu'elle même elle fixe ce
que elle peut entendre ce qu'elle ne
peut pas entendre ce vers quoi elle veut
aller se là où elle veut pas aller et en
fait se pète tout simplement les
participants qui se rendent compte que
ce processus de dialogue là ça va pas
forcément répondre à leurs attentes dans
l'immédiat et donc par conséquent
d'elle-même elle considère que il faut
pas aller plus loin et c'est c'est pas
quelque chose de négatif au contraire on
va les accompagner parfois il va y avoir
la personne victime qui souhaite aller
jusqu'à la rencontre et en face l'autre
participant ne le peut pas parce qu'il
est pas prêt à cela et que ou alors les
animateurs estiment que la sécurité des
personnes n'est pas suffisante et donc
là on le fait pas effectivement mais
tout cela est accompagné et le le fait
de s'arrêter n'est pas forcément le
signe d'un échec l'échec ce serait de
conduire à tout prix Une rencontre et
que dans ce cas là il y est une
victimisation secondaire jusqu'ici ça ne
s'est jamais produit ce genre de choses
parce que justement on accompagne les
personnes dans ce processus là et que on
est très attentif on prend le temps
nécessaire c'est là où on est sur
quelque chose de très complémentaire par
rapport à la justice pénale parce que le
processus là il est calé sur les
participants et les packs aller sur
un processus déterminé à l'avance et à
l'inverse comment est-ce qu'on mesure le
moment où la justice restaurative et
a été au bout de son de son de son
process et à fonctionner en fait comment
vous mesurez c'est les participants qui
le disent tout simplement et alors si on
va poser cette question à Jérôme Moreau
qui voulait intervenir à quel moment on
se dit tiens finalement ça a marché
alors les participants effectivement
vont dire j'aurais simplement répondre à
la question est-ce que parfois ça peut
échouer en tout cas dans un certain
nombre de situations qu'on a pu vivre
notamment dans le cadre des médiations
restauratives
soit parce qu'on retrouve pas les
personnes ou soit parce que l'un des
deux protagonistes ne veut pas et on
peut tout à fait le comprendre parce que
la victime ne souhaite pas du tout
rencontrée un ancien auteur soit parce
que c'est l'auteur qui peut pas
rencontrer sa victime et là
effectivement parfois on se trouve face
à une difficulté et ça nous est arrivé
moi j'en ai conduit vite un an passé des
des opérations de médiation restaurative
et on en a une qui a effectivement
échoué donc des fois ça ça marche pas
mais c'est comme ça il faut se dire que
de toute manière tout n'est pas
miraculeux et que parfois ben voilà ce
dispositif assez limite en revanche ce
qu'on peut dire quand même c'est que
dans toutes les évaluations qu'on a pu
faire dans toutes les rencontres qui ont
été conduites sous l'égide de l'Institut
française de justice restera-t-il avec
laquelle on travaille en lien avec
Benjamin on peut dire quand même que
l'ensemble des victimes et ont trouvé
quand même une issue favorable on
remarqué qu'elles ont pu s'exprimer en
toute liberté et qu'en fin de compte
quelques années après et bien elle
disent que ça leur a permis de surmonter
enfin grande infraction et c'est ça en
fin de compte l'enjeu de la justice
restaurative et ce que je trouve qui est
assez bien fait dans cette justice
restaurative c'est que pour une fois on
est vraiment capable d'évaluer à
dispositif et c'est ça l'enjeu
aujourd'hui de l'aide aux victimes de
demain c'est qu'on est capable d'évaluer
et de dire Blanco ça marche et c'est
pour cela qu'il faut se lancer alors
effectivement c'est peut-être encore un
peu confidentiel mais en tout état de
cause le mouvement est lancé et que
surtout les territoires on est capable
de mener ces opérations il y a le
dispositif qui qui existe alors il y a
donc ce cas de figure on l'a bien je
reste le plus pédagogique possible donc
les mois que j'appelle ça des
face-à-face donc c'est ce que vous
appelez la médiation et puis il y a les
séances collectives là cette sorte de
thérapie collective rencontre organisée
alors je pense en prison entre plusieurs
victimes et des auteurs d'infraction
similaires ils ont pas en face les
victimes pas en face d'elle ceux qui les
ceux qui les ont agressés que ce soit
bien clair dans l'esprit de tout le
monde alors dans le film il s'agit de
vol avec violence voilà ce que le
personnage incarné par Leila Bekhti dit
au délinquant qu'elle a en face d'elle
regardez
je m'appelle Nawel
j'ai 39 ans j'étais agressé dans le
supermarché dans lequel je travaillais à
5 ans
moi je vous le dis tout de suite
j'attends rien de vous je suis là pour
vous dire ce qui se passe pour les
victimes quand vous commettez genre de
choses donc vous compreniez les dégâts
que vous faites dans la vie des gens
comment vous détruisez des vies pour de
l'argent pour vous marrer je sais pas
quoi quand vous attaquez quelqu'un il y
a pas qu'une victime il y a d'autres
victimes derrière il y a des familles
des couples des enfants j'aimerais vous
compreniez ça
j'ai aussi envie d'entendre d'autres
victimes déjà rien que votre rencontre
la dernière fois j'ai vu que ça m'avait
fait du bien de pouvoir échanger avec
vous avec des gens qui comprennent de
quoi je parle et puis plus loin dans le
film je veux pas tout vous raconter
parce que vous irez le voir et bon voilà
le dialogue va quand même s'amorcer avec
les délinquants qu'elle a enfin en face
d'elle Frédéric Giffard moi ce que je
retiens c'est les dommages alors c'est
le terme est pas bon mais de collatéraux
c'est à dire que le fait qu'il y a pas
une victime il y en a plusieurs ça c'est
très important de penser aussi aux
proches à la à la famille et puis
surtout c'est vraiment le personnage
incarné par les like Betty
figé dans le temps quoi c'est à dire que
sa vie s'est arrêtée le jour elle a été
agressée oui alors là on est vraiment
dans le dans tout ce qui est le poste
traumatique et que on connaît maintenant
de mieux en mieux notamment
malheureusement avec les attentats
qu'on a subi en France et défendu
dans les deux
intéressant ce qu'on voit là c'est de ce
point de vue là c'est très intéressant
quand elle dit j'ai besoin de rencontrer
d'autres victimes on a vu dans les
attentats les procès des attentats que
le fait que les victimes se retrouvent
et qui a une communauté de victimes et
qu'elle se reconnaissent dans le récit
des autres ça c'est très important pour
pour la reconstruction de briser
l'isolement dans lequel elles sont les
symptômes post-traumatiques il diminue
aussi quand
[Musique]
elles peuvent s'exprimer librement et
quand la distance avec l'auteur diminue
du fait du dialogue voilà ça c'est
toujours dans l'enceinte pénale il y a
une distance qui est là il y a la
solennité il y a les règles il y a les
contraintes il y a pas de liberté il y a
pas de liberté de de propos il y a pas
de on peut pas on peut même pas
s'adresser la parole directement si vous
voulez entre victimes et auteurs donc
tout ça on le voit très bien ce produire
dans le film c'est presque clinique mais
en même temps c'est très bien joué donc
c'est très sensible et ça ce sont des
choses qu'effectivement
sont
crucial pour pour les victimes
absolument et alors je reste sur le
personnage de Nawel donc incarné par les
laby
elle dit j'ai peur de croiser mon
agresseur il est en fuite peut-être
qu'il va me chercher j'ai peur de de
tomber sur lui et l'un des délinquants
lui dit ben non parce que ce qui va se
passer si ça arrive c'est lui qui va
avoir peur il va avoir peur d'être connu
d'être dénoncé et donc et ça c'est une
espèce de déclic pour elle elle dit ça
m'a retiré un poids énorme est-ce que
vous avez vécu vous des déclics comme
celui-là bien sûr
l'exemple là c'est vraiment assez
typique c'est-à-dire que cette cette
rencontre cette discussion entre les
auteurs et les victimes ça permet de de
lever des des préjugés de lever des
représentations de et c'est vrai
qu'effectivement cette libération de la
parole tous les gens qui ont participé à
ça expriment ce sentiment de libération
de je et je me sens en capacité
d'enviser la suite et le film il porte
parfaitement son nom du côté des auteurs
c'est je verrai toujours vos visages
donc oui quand c'est un auteur de
d'agressions qui dit ça
dans la situation où je j'aurais pu
recommencer voilà c'est c'est ce flash
alors ça on va y revenir parce que
évidemment on va parler de la récidive
et de et de l'efficacité en la matière
mais je voudrais vous entendre c'est
quelque chose là sur l'accompagne le
ministère de la Justice a accompagné ce
film je veux bien que vous nous
racontiez ça il sonne juste ce film
alors ce que les personnes qui jouent
les délinquants les condies on est
exactement dedans moi j'avais
l'impression d'être à l'audience en fait
voilà et même du côté des victimes c'est
juste extrêmement juste parce que
jannerie a été en immersion dans un
service pénitentiaire d'ascension de
probation elle a d'ailleurs passé sa
formation de justice restaurative
générique tout à fait et donc le mystère
de la Justice a accompagné ce tournage
il en accompagne 70 par an et pour que
le fil soit le plus juste possible voilà
le ministère a accompagné jeanneri dans
son travail qui faut saluer
véritablement parce que ça permet
d'améliorer la connaissance Jérôme
Moreau je voyais voilà de demander à
intervenir donc je vous donne la parole
je voulais simplement dire sur pour
rejoindre ce que disait
et sur cette rencontre
un des axes à mon avis les plus
importants de la justice restera-t-il
sont pour les victimes de viol
aujourd'hui on sait que le procès il
serait extrêmement important mais que
beaucoup de victimes ce sont toujours
coupables et la honte repose toujours
sur la victime un rapport à ça et là des
enjeux c'est qu'un auteur design victime
tu n'es coupable de rien vous n'êtes
coupable de rien c'est uniquement nous
qui sommes coupables de tout et c'est ce
qui permet en fin de compte de les
reconstruire et c'est ça l'enjeu de la
justice restaurative alors évidemment le
procès pénal ne le permet pas puisqu'on
est dans une question répressive et
effectivement
le but de l'auteur c'est d'avoir la
peine la moins importante possible et
donc il a ce droit fondamental de ne pas
s'auto incriminer et la justice
restaurative va le permettre parce qu'on
va opposer le répressif à la
restauration à la réparation et à la
vérité et pour une fois dans cette
dispositifs de rencontre auteurs
victimes en dehors du procès pénal et
bien on n'a pas une vérité biaisée en
tout cas on a un rapport à la vérité qui
va être la réelle qui va plus être
l'enjeu du procès et c'est cela qui est
important et pour les victimes de viol
je trouve que c'est absolument essentiel
de pouvoir mener les opérations justice
restauratives on est sur un crime on est
sur quelque chose d'extrêmement grave et
parfois effectivement on voit les
victimes sur construire et l'autre point
quand même qui est important aujourd'hui
moi je pense que c'est également pour
l'effet qui sont prescrits et notamment
pour tous les auteurs d'infraction
sexuelle durant leur enfance et pour les
victimes qui ont subi ces infractions
sexuelles parce que là aussi il y a des
choses à dire il y a des choses
restaurer il y a des choses à comprendre
que le procès pénal de toute manière ne
permettra jamais puisque les faits sont
prescrits et c'est tout l'enjeu aussi de
reconstruction des victimes vous savez
on est très frappé de voir que des
victimes qu'on soit 60 70 ans sont
toujours marqués ont toujours
laisséquelles
d'avioles suivies pendant leur enfance
et que il faut trouver un moyen et sa
justice restaurative aujourd'hui est la
des dispositifs majeurs et puis Frédéric
gifard la libération de la parole le
mouvement me too fait que des des
affaires des à juger va y en avoir de
plus en plus et je heureusement
malheureusement parce qu'elles existent
et heureusement parce que la parole se
libère est-ce que la justice est prête à
juger pénalement tous les auteurs de
fait dont on parle je crains que non je
crains que non on a enfin conscience de
l'ampleur du phénomène de l'ampleur en
termes de nombre et en termes de
conséquences et de gravité des
conséquences et de durer des
conséquences comme le disait Jérôme
Moreau
vous allez nous dire je vais vous dire
que la justice pénale n'est pas apte
aujourd'hui à traiter ça c'est pas
possible elle ne peut pas encaisser ce
choc-là
c'est pour ça qu'il faut trouver autre
chose c'est pour ça qu'il faut proposer
une alternative selon moi aux victimes
parce qu'on peut pas on peut pas d'un
côté dire ah bah maintenant on sait
qu'il y a des violences sexuelles les
viols c'est mal et puis d'un autre côté
laissez cette situation
qui pour de bonnes et de mauvaises
raisons attention la justice pénale
c'est c'est un manque de moyens c'est
aussi des droits de la des droits de la
défense qui sont absolument
cruciaux pour protéger les libertés
individuelles pour protéger contre
l'arbitraire donc ça il faut pas y
toucher c'est juste un système qui ne
fonctionne pas qui ne fonctionne pas non
plus parce que souvent dans les
violences sexuelles et en particulier
celles qui sont commises par quelqu'un
qu'on connaît
l'important pour la victime c'est pas
d'envoyer l'auteur en prison c'est pas
la sanction c'est comme le disait Jérôme
Moreau c'est que l'auteur reconnaisse
que c'est lui qui a commis la faute il
faut qu'on vise à l'essentiel de ce dont
tu as besoin à la victime et c'est là
qu'on va pouvoir trouver une solution
parce que jamais les tribunaux ne
pourront traiter ces monceaux et ses
monos déjà avant ni tout ça ne marchait
pas les dossiers restent traînent
pendant des années dans les tuyaux
l'effet prescrit c'est un vrai problème
parce que il faut pas revenir sur la
prescription en a réformé déjà la
prescription on est déjà allé très loin
il faut pas ouvrir ça encore plus
important de garder la différence entre
les crimes contre l'humanité et les
crimes sexuels bon
donc c'est votre avis c'est mon avis
personnel je connais bien Andrea Bescond
qui se bat absolument une prise
absolument il y a plusieurs avis moi
c'est mon avis de de juriste et de
praticienne mais
il y a cette voix là qui est possible et
qui permettrait en effet de d'absorber
ce choc là alors ça ouvre un débat
Cédric Jean qui est pas facile je pense
qu'il y a certainement une partie des
téléspectateurs étaient spectatrices qui
vous entendent dire ça qui qui ont du
mal à accepter l'idée qui est pas de
procès dans le cas des crimes sexuels
alors il peut ne pas y avoir de procès
parce que les faits sont prescrits en
l'état actuel du droit français il y a
des limites de prescription à partir
desquels et bien il ne pourra pas y
avoir de procès mais il pourrait y avoir
une mesure de justice restaurative il
peut y avoir des relax il peut y avoir
mieux que rien quoi c'est ce que vous
nous dites
mieux qu'un procès pardon mais ce que ce
que disait monsieur saillou sur cette
interaction directe entre auteur et
victime c'est quelque chose qui n'est
possible que dans la justice
restaurative puisque lors de l'audience
et bien victime et auteur ne peuvent pas
s'interpeller comme le fait les la Betty
dans le film il faut toujours répondre
au président d'audience même si on a
envie de poser des questions directement
d'interpeller la personne qui nous a
fait du mal on ne peut pas ce n'est
possible que dans le cadre de la justice
restaurative c'est pour ça qu'il y a il
y a un vrai avec cette justice restaurée
alors je vous propose d'entendre une
réaction de la réalisatrice du film dont
on a évidemment beaucoup parlé dans ce
débat c'est Jeanne Hery elle était sur
France Inter il y a quelques jours c'est
une justice qui qui travaille à la
réparation psychique de ceux qui ont été
abîmés par une infraction que ce soit
des auteurs des victimes ou même le lien
social en général et ça fait tomber les
fantasmes on a on va dire qu'on
progresse dans la compréhension des
autres et de nous-mêmes c'est juste
reprendre confiance en soi reprendre
confiance dans les autres en général par
le dialogue et ça c'est c'est des
mécanismes en fait qui sont hyper
puissants donc elle parle aussi
évidemment des auteurs et j'aurais qu'on
termine ce débat sur la question de la
récidive peut-être avec votre avis
Jérôme Moreau est-ce que vous pensez que
la justice restaurative et peut-être
d'ailleurs qu'il y a des il y a des
chiffres nous disiez que ouais il y a
des métriques c'est possible de
d'évaluer l'efficacité limite la
récidive le taux de récidive en tout cas
c'est l'un des enjeux c'est pas le seul
à la justice restaurative il faut bien
comprendre que c'est l'un des enjeux et
l'un des objectifs en tout cas c'est ce
pourquoi on croit c'est ce pourquoi on
se bat et effectivement
l'idée c'est effectivement de répondre à
cela je suis aussi d'accord sur l'idée
que c'est pas parce que un crime est
prescrit qui doit être passé sous
silence et donc il faut trouver les
moyens de pouvoir
faire en sorte que l'auteur puisse
répondre à sa victime en tout cas puisse
dire des choses et que la victime puis
dire des choses à son auteur et moi
aussi je suis d'accord les prescriptions
sont essentielles et que voilà je
voulais redire qu'on était aussi
d'accord avec l'idée qu'il sur l'effet
prescrit quand même il faut prendre je
sais pas si l'un de vous à les chiffres
peut-être Cédric logelin sur le taux de
récidive alors c'est quoi le taux de
récidive parce que la justice
restera-t-il on peut l'appliquer à tous
les crimes et tous les délits donc il
faudrait en fait obtenir le chiffre de
récidive général de toute la population
pénale chose que je n'ai pas là d'accord
alors ce qui est
utile pour qui se restaurative c'est que
ça aide l'auteur à se rendre compte de
ce qu'il a créé chez une personne alors
qu'avant il se représentait une maison
il se représentait des objets à les
volets ils se représentait un bien mais
il n'avait pas conscience que derrière
cette maison qu'il a été cambriolée
derrière ce sac qu'il a été arraché et
bien il y a une personne qui ne sort
plus de chez elle il y a une personne
qui a peur en rentrant chez elle le soir
et le fait de pouvoir entendre ce que ce
type d'acte a créé vise et aide à
réduire la récidive un curseur de la
violence qui est pas le même quoi c'est
à dire que j'ai mis des petites claques
bah oui mais c'est des couilles
exactement que ça peut traumatiser
quelqu'un quoi exactement c'est aussi ça
que alors je vous posais la même
question peut-être en tournant vers les
pays où ça existe depuis plus longtemps
toujours sur la récidive
Benjamin salut
il y a eu trop peu de mesure mais c'est
vrai que dans enfin il y a pas mal
d'études qui ont été conduites dans
d'autres pays qui beaucoup plus en
avance que nous et c'est vrai que alors
ça varie selon les études mais avec des
études qui avaient groupes de contrôle
donc des personnes qui ont même profil
bah on voit entre 25 et 35 % de
récidives en moins lorsqu'on a participé
à la justice restaurative après le comme
je dis les études sont très variées
et c'est pas un objectif premier de la
justice restaurative évitez la récidive
mais par contre lorsque l'on travaille
avec l'auteur que l'auteur rencontre la
victime qui prend conscience d'un
certain nombre de choses il se
responsabilise et ça c'est clair que
c'est un effet accélérateur sur tout ce
processus long compliqué pour un auteur
de sortir de la criminalité de la
délinquance donc ça a un effet tout à
fait positif c'est clair il y a eu un
peu plus de 500 000 spectateurs qui ont
déjà vu le film de janeiry je verrai
toujours vos visages ça va peut-être on
le disait c'est avec le joint suscité
des vocations est-ce que le système est
prêt à accueillir beaucoup plus de
demandes de oui puisque on a déjà des
services qui la mettent en oeuvre et
ensuite ça peut susciter mais pas que du
côté des victimes du côté des
professionnels c'est le but aussi de ce
film c'est que quelque part un conseil
d'insertion un magistrat et bien et
l'idée de réunir le barreau le SPIP les
conseillers pour bien pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre chez lui de la justice
restaurative et pouvoir la mettre à
disposition des victimes ce film va
aider et pas que les victimes votre avis
là-dessus moi je crois qu'il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup de travail parce que
on sait très bien quand on oriente nos
clients vers les structures que parfois
ça suit pas derrière parce qu'il faut
que les gens soient très formés parce
que c'est des process qui sont longs
dans le temps la préparation on le voit
dans le film c'est un vrai travail de de
dentelle mais le film moi je crois
beaucoup au pouvoir de la fiction pour
pour changer les perceptions pour
irriguer la culture commune avec des
approches différentes et comme c'est
quand même un changement culturel
important
le film est très important pour ça
j'espère que beaucoup beaucoup de gens
le verront et que voilà que le pouvoir
que le que le politique sera obligé de
suivre et que les débats
s'enrichiront de tout ça qu'est-ce que
vous attendez
la question c'est la fin de l'émission
sud je suis vraiment désolé parce que en
général j'essaye de ne pas vous empêcher
de poser des questions va-t-il mais là
c'est vraiment terminé merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat ici en
plateau et en duplex merci à l'équipe du
film de nous avoir fourni des extraits
la bande-annonce évidemment il est
toujours en salle à les voir je verrai
toujours vos visages c'est un superbe
film il ne faut pas le manquer voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission je vous
dis à demain donc exceptionnellement
vendredi pour un numéro spécial de sens
public consacré à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel sur la réforme des
retraites et le référendum d'initiative
partagez on va analyser la décision du
conseil et ses conséquences politiques
et justement demain dans la matinale
rien de Mancini reçoit un
constitutionnaliste c'est Dominique
Rousseau professeur de droit
constitutionnel à Paris un bonne soirée
à toutes et à tous et à demain 18h
[Musique]